Oprah cooked up another surprise is it's
something I'll never forget and Josh
surprises me at work okay we're on our
way to the office now
getting all jittery well then you know
what you ought to have a really good
time at the concert oh my God
hold on a second nobody has any idea you
guys
this better not be your people
Oprah called me up because I was going
to see you that night I've seen Josh in
concert four times I was and she was
saying you're gonna have a really great
time in this camera crew walks and I'm
like who are you people and then you
walk in Josh I'll never forget that I'll
never forget and you were singing the
song to Oprah on the phone yes when you
say you love me that I wound up singing
to you that day surprises are hard but
yeah but you pulled that off